so the past couple of weeks President
Trump has been rated railing against the
trade treachery of our neighbor to the
north Canada Canada has replaced China
as trumps new Bugaboo at the same time
Trump turned his anger against the evil
Canucks
he said China was not a currency
manipulator that's because Trump is now
attempting to appeal to the blue-collar
workers in the swing states who've been
harmed by Canada's protectionism there's
nothing wrong with Trump ripping
Canadian protectionism on milk
importation it's true the Canada has
been terrifying American milk products
in order to subsidize its domestic
farming industry here's what Trump
tweeted today quote Canada has made
business for our dairy farmers in
Wisconsin and other border states very
difficult we will not stand for this
watch but it's Trump solution that's
sort of a problem instead of pressuring
candidates and lower its tariffs on
Wisconsin milk Trump has decided to
retaliate via tariffs of zone with no
sign that he's using those tariffs as
leverage to tamp down protectionism from
the Trudeau administration on Monday
night Trump announced a conservative
allies he would put a quote
countervailing duty of somewhere between
three and 24% on Canadian lumber United
States by nearly 80% of all Canadian
softwood lumber exports this means
builders will pay the price for Trump
state's trade retaliation as Cato
Institute pointed out a decade and a
half ago quote the resulting addition of
800 to 1300 dollars to the cost of a new
home prices some 300,000 families out of
the housing market workers in the major
lumber using sectors outnumber logging
and sawmill workers by better than 25 to
one but this tariff does pay off
domestic loggers are celebrating along
with their Democratic representatives
Senator Ron Wyden is a radical leftist
and he called the move a quote message
that helped us on the way herein lies
the problem the truth is that the trade
dispute over lumber has nothing to do
with the trade dispute over dairy the
issues are not linked America has had a
long-standing dispute with Canada over
lumber for the past three decades but
Trump likes tariffs and he wants to
raise them he has a particular
constituency that he wants to protect
and just as Democrats do with domestic
spending he's going to use trade to help
them out through indirect taxation
that's why Trump has blamed NAFTA for
Canadian trade intransigence
which doesn't make a lot of sense
considering that NAFTA lowered tariffs
rather than raising them if Trump were
using the new lumber tariffs as leverage
for future negotiations that would be
understandable but it appears he's just
using milk dispute as a trigger for the
protectionism he so desperately seeks
look for more punitive measures that
harm American producers and consumers
from the Trump administration
unfortunately I'm Ben Shapiro this is
the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
so tons of breaking news this morning
we're going to get to the latest on Mike
Flynn it now appears that Mike Flynn may
have broken the law and the White House
is sort of stonewalling for him which is
really not good
meanwhile we will talk about the
government shutdown which does not just
from salt Republicans do not know how to
handle government shutdowns and we're
going to talk about what they actually
should be doing on all of this plus I
want to talk about a poll that is really
disturbing to me but first we are going
to say thank you to our advertisers over
at Boleyn branch so I've spoken about
the wonders of bowland branch for months
now on the program and I mean every word
I say I am NOT a good sleeper I sleep
really poorly I said really lightly it
got to the point where after I got these
Bull and bran treats Boleyn branch makes
the greatest sheets in the business they
had organic cotton really comfortable
they really breathe now that I've slept
on or these Bull and bran sheets I
literally cannot sleep on any other
sheets they have ruined other sheets for
pee because the sheets are such
qualities bull and branch compro moko
betting get $50 off your first set of
sheets plus free shipping the sheets are
like 200 bucks for a set of sheets which
if you're talking about really really
high quality sheets actually is not a
lot of money Plus remember you're
sleeping on them every single night so
they are super duper comfortable as I
say they breathe they're like half the
price of expensive retail markup and yet
twice the quality of the stuff that
you're going to get at your local
retailer because this is they just are
the best you can try them for 30 nights
see for yourself you don't like them you
can send them back for a full refund
everybody who tries them likes them
that's why 3x president + Bill Clinton's
lovers sleep on bull and branch sheets
Boehm branch is just the company is
great the product is fantastic if you go
to bull and branch come today you get
$50 off your first set of sheets plus
free shipping when you use that promo
code Ben Bo LL and branch con promo code
Ben as I say frequently it's one of
those things that will make you feel
rich even if you are not because
sleeping on a luxurious set of sheets is
really top-notch and as I say it's so
good that I can't sleep on other sheets
now we bought a bunch of sets on our own
initiative because we can't sleep on any
other sheet poland branch the best in
the business okay so a lot to talk about
today i want to start off with this poll
from Pew Research that is deeply
troubling to me and should be troubling
to all conservatives that is this poll
shows that more Americans now want
bigger government with more services now
the trumpet
president so if that seems
counterintuitive it shouldn't be the
fact is the Trump did not campaign on
the basis of small government he
campaigned on cutting some regulations
he campaigned on the basis of cutting
waste fraud and abuse but when it came
to funding of programs it's hard to find
a program he wanted he funded other than
the EPA and foreign aid every other
program he wanted to increase funding
Veterans Affairs want increased funding
military spending one to increase
funding on the entitlement programs he
wanted to increase funding he wanted to
increase funding on health care because
he said that nobody should should be
left out on the street and all the rest
of it Trump is not a small government
guy the era of small government
according to Republicans apparently is
over so the poll shows that Americans
now want more spending on programs
ranging from veterans benefits and
services to infrastructure from Medicare
to health care from defense to
environmental protection from Social
Security as to assistance to the needy
all of them Americans now want more more
government than they did back in
February 2013 when Barack Obama had just
been reelected and was starting his
second term so for example veterans
benefits and services fifty-three
percent of Americans wanted more funding
for that in February 2013 today that is
seventy five percent let's take one that
lefties like let's take assistance to
the needy in the United States listen we
all like assistance to the needy I want
to be done through private organizations
the left Florence is done through
government only twenty one percent of
Americans in February 2013 thought that
the government should provide more
assistance to the needy today that
number is twenty nine percent it's risen
by eight percent since Donald Trump has
taken office government assistance to
the unemployed it's up five percent from
24 to 29
sorry assistance indeed in the world is
from 21 to 29 assistance to the needy in
the United States is up from 27 percent
to 45 percent an 18 point jump from the
Obama era so what's happening here well
it's happening here is obviously
unfortunately it now appears that a lot
of the small government rhetoric of a
lot of people on the right
it was just reactionary tribalism
directed at Barack Obama as soon as they
got one of their own in then all of a
sudden all the small government rhetoric
went completely out the window because
we like Trump but we didn't like Obama
so it's bad when Obama spent but it's
good when Trump spends this is stupidity
it's just silliness and you can see that
a lot of this shift is coming from
Republicans not from Democrats in 2013
only 28% of Republicans wanted increased
spending on roads and infrastructure 21%
wanted less spending on those things
today 55
Republicans want increase spending on
infrastructure that is due to Donald
Trump and it's also due to the fact that
Republicans have bought into I think all
Americans unfortunately have now bought
into the idea that the government can
fix your problems the government cannot
fix your problems and you are seeing
this from mainstream Republicans you've
seen it for years from mainstream
Republicans today the obvious example
comes from John Kasich so John Kasich is
the Governor of Ohio who I could not
stand in the primaries as you remember
every time John Kasich spoke during the
primaries I said oh god no please God
not John Kasich
oh yes John Kasich Governor of Ohio and
MSNBC this morning listen to how he
describes President Trump my wife says
you're the father of Ohio why don't you
act like it but it's in the book and I
changed and you know when you're running
a big job like that you have to not only
use your head but your heart and they
have to work together and what he needs
to know is he's the father of America
and and that carries a heavy
responsibility he's tweeting less
because he did it less than a hundred
days and give the guy chances my view
and you look there's nobody that has
been look I didn't endorse him I didn't
go to the convention I want them to be
successful I'm going to give him a
chance yeah okay to paraphrase triumph
the comic insult dog I poop on this okay
the idea that John Kasich is the father
of Ohio Donald Trump is the father of
America I'm old enough to remember when
Chris Rock said about Barack Obama that
he was like the country's dad and
Republicans and conservatives said are
you out of your mind he's not like my
dad I don't need Obama as my dad I have
a dad but adds great okay I don't need
Barack Obama or Donald Trump or John
Kasich to be my dad because government
is not my parent government is there to
do a job to defend and protect my rights
but it is not there to be my mommy or my
daddy but now you have Republicans
including John Kasich and I think to a
certain extent Trump buying into the
generalized idea only I can solve okay
only you can solve let's be real about
this Trump cannot solve your problems
only you in a free country can solve
your problems John Kasich cannot solve
your problems only you in a free country
can solve your problems and it's idiotic
notion that government is supposed to
sit over us and fix all of our problems
is really a Democrat Left notion this
idea that Trump can do it with tariffs
this idea that Trump is going to change
the economics in the working of
economics to protect his specific group
of people it is no better than Democrats
using
direct taxation to redistribute wealth
to use indirect taxation to redistribute
wealth but I think Republicans have
bought into this big government nonsense
and it really is upsetting and it
demonstrates the the moral corruptness
of a movement that claimed that it was
small government through and through and
then turns around and says that it's not
small government anymore as soon as
somebody they like ISM and blow out the
spending that's really dishonest and
it's dishonest in a huge way you can see
that it's honesty when it comes to the
government shutdown so Donald Trump
wants his wall funded by Congress it
should be funded by Congress we should
have a physical barrier on the southern
border it should either be fencing or a
wall it should be monitored we shouldn't
have people crossing the border
illegally I was for a wall before Trump
was and after the Trump wall is not
built presumably I still will be for the
Trump wall when Trump aside he kept his
promise bottom line is that Trump says
he wants funding for the wall and
Republicans in Congress go and Democrats
in Congress going to say no way we're
not going to do it if you do that we
will shut down the government we will
not pass a budget with funding for your
stupid wall in it so what does Trump do
Trump backs down and Republicans back
down Trump and Republicans say no you
know what we've decided differently
we're not going to do that anymore you
know screw it no big deal we'll move off
of it okay this is why Republicans
cannot be trusted to cut the government
here's how the logic should work
Republicans are making the case for
decades that small government is better
that is Ronald Reagan put at the problem
in America is not you the problem is the
government the government is the problem
right that was Ronald Reagan's case so
is the problem less of it would be a
good thing so Republicans to a certain
extent should be rooting for a
government shutdown because vital
essential services continue to be
performed the military continues to
operate the the social services like
Social Security it continues get paid
those are considered essential services
that are not cut when there is a
government shutdown people continue to
work right that's just the way that this
system works
but Republicans are so damn scared of
government shutdowns that they think
that it's going to crush them now let's
examine that for a second if you're a
Republican why are you scared of a
government shutdown you're advocating
for it cuts to government every single
day why are you scared of a government
shutdown shouldn't you say okay fine
shut down the government let's see what
happens is that rigging to die right
you're the ones who want the government
open you tell me why the government
should stay open you explain to me why
the government should stay open
on the terms that you want and if you
want to shut down the government fine we
can all exist without the government we
can all exist without the government
doing all of these stupid things that
the government is doing you know how
meaningless the government shutdown was
during when Cruz and the Republicans
tried to defund Obamacare and there's a
government shutdown for like a month you
know how little it mattered you know
little it mattered it mattered so little
that Barack Obama in order to show you
how much it mattered had to forcibly
shut open air national parks that's how
little it mattered because you couldn't
come up with a victim zombies weren't
stalking the streets there weren't
people being shot on maps there wasn't
mass chaos it wasn't the purge right
nothing bad was happening so Obama in
order to show how terrible was that the
government had shut down had to forcibly
shot like the World War Two memorial and
ban people in wheelchairs from going and
visiting the memorial for their buddies
that's how he had to do that
specifically in order to demonstrate how
terrible how terrible the government
shutdown was he said national pirates
right which was nothing nothing to
operate because just redirected money he
could have just redirected money and
kept them up and but he wanted people to
feel the suffering and the only way he
could make people feel the suffering was
to shut down national parks Republicans
should have said is dude if that's all
this is like you're shutting down
national parks here's a bill to reopen
the national parks and let's just leave
everything else closed Republicans in
other words conservatives should not be
afraid of government shutdowns because
we're constantly making the case that
not only should there be a temporary
government shutdown a lot of these
programs should just die they should
just go away
we shouldn't have them at all and yet
Republicans tree government shutdowns
like they're the end of the world and
Democrats treat government shutdowns
like well you know it'll just redound to
our benefit what's the big deal if
there's a government shutdown you know
why that is it's because both parties
have been complicit in pushing the
notion that big government is good for
you it does not make sense for a small
government party to be scared of a
government shutdown it only makes sense
for a big government party to be scared
of a government shutdown and right now
Trump has the perfect ground to stand on
so I want to flash back to the last
government shutdown this is the shutdown
that happened over Obamacare and here is
what Barack Obama said about the
government shutdown and this was an
Obama did what a president should do
during a government shutdown he's a
terrible president but he did what a
president should do he blamed it on the
opposing party and he said here is their
priority they think is so important and
here is why the government shouldn't be
shut down over that priority here's what
Obama did at midnight last night for
time in 17 years Republicans in Congress
chose to shut down the federal
government it might be more specific one
faction of one party in one house of
Congress in one branch of government
shut down major parts of the government
all because they didn't like one law
this Republican shutdown did not have to
happen but I want every American to
understand why it didn't happen
Republicans in the House of
Representatives refused to fund the
government unless we defunded or
dismantled the Affordable Care Act okay
so he was blaming it on Republicans
don't want Obamacare funded so the case
he was making is they shouldn't have
shut down the government over they hate
the Affordable Care Act why can't Trump
make that same case of you shouldn't
shut down the government just because
you don't want to fund a border wall it
demonstrates how your open border
globalist right this is his entire case
this is his case for being president I
am NOT an open borders globalist the
Democrats are that's why we need a wall
on the border shouldn't he be out there
screaming in favor of a government
shutdown if the Democrats are going to
do it fine you don't want to fund the
government because you want to keep that
border open so anyone who wants you can
cross it fine
your problem let's play this game right
this is a game of chicken this is a game
of chicken and what Republicans
constantly do is they don't understand
how the game of chicken works so not to
drop a tweet thread game theory on you
okay but there's a basic concept in game
theory called chicken right and this is
the way that it works if there are two
people who are running a car directly at
each other their worst outcome is if
nobody swerves right that's the worst
outcome for both parties nobody swerves
and there's a crash the second dorset
outcome is if you're the guy who swerves
then the other car just keeps driving
straight forward that's the second worst
outcome the best and the best outcome
for you isn't the other guy swerves
that's the best outcomes with the other
guys worse
so how do you make the other guy swerve
in a game of chicken the way that you
make the other guys form in a game of
chicken is you demonstrate openly and
obviously to the other person that you
are not going to swerve no matter what
you put a brick on the accelerator and
you take the club and you put it on the
steering wheel
I cannot swerve now I've pre committed
to not swerving so either you're going
to swerve or you're gonna get the crash
but you have no choices right and the
worst of those two options for you is to
get in the crash
so you swerve right in
said what Republicans do is they priests
were they say we're not going to shut
down the government they always say that
we're not going to shut down the
government under no circumstances are we
going to shut down the government you
idiot if you if you want to lose these
standoff that is the government shutdown
continue to be this stupid
right Barack Obama was perfectly happy
with the shutdown he was perfectly happy
with the shutdown but here was Mitch
McConnell talking about the shutdown at
exactly the same time which to the issue
of potential government shutdown you
probably know that Democrats are making
a big deal out of comments that you made
talking about the strategy that you
would use if you became majority leader
to use spending bills to change policies
and that that tends to eat it that you
didn't rule out a government shutdown
can you just say well I did rule it out
I'm going to get this out of shutdown
remember me I'm the guy to get this out
of shutdown and but that doesn't mean
that Congress has an obligation to send
appropriation bills to the present that
are a blank check which is the way it's
been with the Democratic Senate one of
the powers of Congress is to direct
spending and we have an abusive
bureaucracy across the board it's been
particularly bad here in Kentucky with
the EPA in the coal industry it needs to
have some directions from Congress the
Senate
McConnell says shut down to our failed
policy e shutdowns are not a failed
policy shutdowns our failed policy if
you lose okay I don't understand how
this works so when Barack Obama is
President the shutdown hurts the
Republicans when Trump is president the
shutdown hurts the Republicans how does
this work exactly it's just insanity I
want to talk a little bit more about
this in just a second and the in the
reaction that people should be having to
the to the wall and all the rest of this
but first I want to say thank you to our
sponsors over at my Patriot supply so if
you are concerned about North Korea
developing a nuke if you are concerned
about North quake if you're concerned
about a tornado if you're concerned
about a flood if you're concerned in any
case that there's going to be some sort
of disaster for which you need resources
then you owe it to yourself and your
family go to prepare with Ben comprehend
calm eight eight eight eight o 31413 get
your ford week emergency food supply for
only $99 plus free shipping right now if
you go to prepare with Ben Calm it's all
of this food that makes sure you and
your family are fed you buy it now you
don't have to worry about because it
lasts
forever lasts a long long time it tastes
like home cooking according to folks in
the studio who've actually tasted it
it's prepared with been calm and again
that makes sure that you and your family
are safe against a one-time cost is 99
bucks you never have to worry about it
again you take any stash in the closet
and then you never have to worry about
it until that time when you should
actually be worried you go oh I remember
I went from prepare with been calm and
that's when I bought all of my food I
bought my emergency food supply and so I
don't have to worry while everybody
outside is starving in the zombie
apocalypse you don't have to worry about
it if you go to prepare with been calm
right now and check it out so go over
there and get to your four-week
emergency food supply for just $99 you
owe it to yourself and to your family to
do that so what actually gets shut down
during it during a government shutdown
what actually gets shut down during a
government shutdown is they delay
unemployment insurance they delay
veteran's benefits maybe maybe that's
unclear national parks museums and
passport offices whatever the Small
Business Administration and FHA don't
guarantee you loan applications which is
probably a good thing considering the
half of what they're guaranteeing are
bad loans the private industry wouldn't
wouldn't give farm subsidy checks
stopped flowing Oh No farm subsidies an
IRS tax processing would slow down oh no
it turns out the IRS won't be able to
audit you that's so terrible oh no what
are we ever going to do without the IRS
auditing people social security checks
continue to go military spending
continued to continues to happen
Commerce and labor departments shut down
oh no that's so terrible all of this is
temporary by the way right tsa continues
to Bob to bother you FBI VA all this
continues to function disaster relief
continues to function the Postal Service
continues to deliver the mail the
Federal Reserve continues to work right
so basically the parts of the government
that people consider vital and many that
aren't vital continue to operate in the
government shutdown but Republicans are
so scared because they're all pansies
they're so scared of this stupid
government shutdown the in people are
asking but about IRS tax returns how
about my tax refund yes the IRS will be
slower to process your tax refund it
will also be slower to audit you you can
honest-to-god like I think you're better
off with the IRS failing to audit you
it's not a tax refund it's your money in
the first place
so if you said maybe you'd be better off
for there to be a government shutdown if
they're going to do one let's do it like
April 10th right before tax season and
then they can't even process your tax
returns you're going to have to turn
them
presumably but here's the thing if the
wall is that important if the wall is
that important then you should be
willing to stand up against the
Democrats on this and say exactly what
Barack Obama said and say look the
people who are shutting this down are
the Democrats it's not me and they're
shutting it down to prevent a wall from
being built that will protect all
Americans
isn't that a publicity win for them
isn't that a publicity win but you can
see the Trump administration fussing
around on this because a big government
party has to avoid a government shutdown
here's Sean Spicer being asked about
Mexico funding the wall and the funding
battle that in order to get the ball
rolling on border security in the wall
that he was going to have to use the
appropriations process but he would make
sure that that promise would be kept as
far as the payment of it by hey if
you're coming in from our southern
border they're taken a lot of steps so
far that is deterred border crossing but
this is a permanent step that will
extend beyond his presidency eight years
from now the next president will have
that wall in place to make sure that
that doesn't continues okay so he says
that he is getting it built and sure
Mexico will eventually pay for it you
should be angry with Trump if Trump is
not willing to go to the mat on this
thing you should be angry with him and I
understand he doesn't want the bad
headlines on day 100 or whatever but who
cares show some backbone here show some
backbone this was your key issue shows
him back on Charles Krauthammer I think
mimics the talk of Democrats when he
says the Democrats have the advantage
here was his take on this and I think
this is totally wrong people accept the
Berrier idea but if you look at the
polling on the wall I think the
Democrats had the advantage I don't
particularly understand why anybody
would object to a barrier of any sort at
the border even if it's marginally
effective okay so you know this idea
that the wall is unpopular so Trump will
lose this battle no he won't
the reason that he won't lose this
battle is because what the polls show is
that Americans don't care all that much
about the wall but if Trump makes this
battle about one side wants there to be
no barrier whatsoever so people can
enter illegally and they're willing to
shut down the government for it that's a
winning political battle and you should
stand by the power of his idea rather
than caving to the power of big
government which is unfortunately what I
think that the Republican Party in large
measure has become which is really quite
terrible well as we continue here at the
daily
we're going to talk about everything
that's happening with Mike Flynn there's
there's some big news breaking it looks
like Mike Flynn may be in some deeper
trouble former national security adviser
it's going to heat up for the White
House which is not good news and we're
also going to be talking about the
battle that's broken out on cable
between Fox News and CNN over sexual
harassment and all the rest plus I have
to play you the most ridiculous video in
the history of mankind Bill Nye has now
cut the most ridiculous video in the
history of mankind but to see it you'll
actually have to subscribe over at daily
wire.com $8 a month get to a
subscription over a daily wire if you
become an annual subscriber you get a
free copy of the arroyo fictional film
set on the southern border all about why
we need a wall okay the entire film is
about a rancher who's facing down drug
cartels using his land as a thoroughfare
really good movie can get that for free
when you become an annual subscriber or
if you're just a subscriber go over to
Daley we're calm right now subscribe
watch the rest of the show live waka
Munich fun and Bill and I and and be
part of the mailbag and a couple updates
to check that out plus if you if you
don't want to subscribe right now you
just wanna listen later go to iTunes or
SoundCloud they come and subscriber
they're subscribed iTunes and leave us a
review we always appreciate it we are
the largest conservative podcast in the
nation
[Music]
you